y llegamos al líbano porque hoy se
cumplen dos años de la explosión del
puerto de beirut hablamos con nuestra
corresponsal en esa ciudad del bonete la
saludo ya para usted muy buena tarde las
responsabilidades por esta explosión aún
no han sido claras le pregunto qué ha
pasado con la investigación de este caso
de tel
buenos días para que raúl y bueno
lamentablemente
lo que es la investigación para
esclarecer las causas de la explosión
del puerto de beirut de 2020 considerada
la mayor catástrofe nuclear de la
historia pues están simplemente
paralizadas ha habido mucha
interferencia política que ha
ralentizado el proceso de investigación
y actualmente el juez encargado de las
pesquisas el juez tal evitar está no
digamos suspendido pero si la
investigación está suspendida por un
tiempo porque está siendo investigado ya
que hay una serie de ex parlamentarios y
ex ministros que han puesto una serie de
denuncias contra el juez porque quieren
inhabilitar lo y esto ha hecho que de
momento desde diciembre del año pasado
no haya avanzado la investigación
ha habido como repito una clara
y digamos que intencionada forma de
obstruir la justicia y las labores del
juez para evitar porque cuando él ha
intentado llamar a declarar a los altos
cargos encausados como es el caso del
general abbas e ibrahim el jefe de la
todopoderosa agencia de seguridad
general no ha ido a declarar en ninguna
de las ocasiones y también pidió que se
levantaran la inmunidad parlamentaria de
los encausados pero el parlamento ha
apoyado claramente a estos encausados
claro por esa razón y justo ahora cuando
se cumple el segundo aniversario de la
explosión del puerto de beirut tanto los
familiares como organizaciones
internacionales locales e
internacionales han pedido al consejo de
seguridad de la onu perdón al consejo
derechos humanos de la onu que se haga
una investigación transparente y que
haya eso una investigación internacional
debido a que el líbano ha demostrado que
no puede haber justicia él también los y
los que resistieron se derrumbaron
parcialmente hace ya unos días qué
pasará con ellos
bueno lo que es el colapso de los silos
del puerto de beirut digamos que es una
crónica de una muerte anunciada ya en el
mes de abril el gobierno interino aprobó
un proyecto de ley para la demolición de
estos silos pero que sufrieron digamos
el contratiempo de parlamentarios y de
las familias de las víctimas del puerto
que pusieron un recurso para que no se
demoliera el puerto si se hubiera
manteniendo quiero decir los silos del
puerto y se seguirán manteniendo como
una prueba pero hace unas semanas debido
a las fuertes temperaturas que están
habiendo en verano y también a que se
está fermentando el grano en los silos
del puerto hubieron una serie de
incendios que han debilitado muchísimo
más esta estructura de hormigón armado y
cuatro de los silos cayeron el pasado
domingo y los expertos dicen que
probablemente va a ser inminente la
caída de los y los 5 al 10 lo que sería
una situación muy trágica muy dramática
para los habitantes del centro de beirut
porque podrían revivir de nuevo
ese momento de la explosión del 4 de
agosto de 2020 claro que él también le
preguntó se espera que en unos días
llegue este buque razón y con el maíz
desde ucrania aliviará en algo la
llegada de cereales a esta crisis que
vive el yo no
bueno pues la verdad es que es la mejor
noticia que podía llegar aquí al líbano
la verdad y es que estamos hablando de
que el líbano es un país que lleva tres
años hundido en una profunda crisis
económica que ha llevado al 80% de la
población libanesa a vivir bajo el
umbral de la pobreza y esto sumado a la
crisis de alimentaria global
ha hecho que el líbano se convierta en
un país de inseguridad alimenticia
el silo del puerto de beirut que era
donde estaba almacenado gran parte del
trigo y de todo el grano quedó
totalmente inutilizado y después con la
guerra de ucrania porque el líbano
importa el 80% de su grano desde ucrania
pues han sido unos meses realmente muy
duros para el país hasta tanto que se
han vivido situaciones muy dramáticas en
las colas del pan donde la gente se
estaba peleando entre ella para poder
conseguir una bolsa de pan árabe
subsidiado y la verdad es que si está
previsto que probablemente llegue mañana
el barco razón y para líbano será
temporalmente un gran alivio para una
población que está tan hambrienta